our amount will stop making transformer
movies when you stop watching them on a
streak of lightning or so he tells his
friends more powerful than the pounding
surf pounding surfing his pet name for
Aquaman mightier than a roaring
hurricane or what Chicagoans call kids
day this amazing stranger from the
planet Krypton the Man of Steel Clark
Kent I mean I'm in real trouble
possessing remarkable physical strength
Superman fights a never-ending battle
for truth and justice disguised as a
mild-mannered newspaper reporter Clark
Kent
not very well disguise but come on for
an alien from another world pretty good
Superman fighting creaking frogs
chirping crickets and Muppets who toss
backwards to teach you the force which
is the murder of theme from The Addams
Family
another Friday night for a young Norman
date flash this cartoon is about the
flash sorry for the Superman credits the
new Justice League movie Acronis off of
it has just been found in the marsh
flats outside the city
he has been identified as a watchman at
the metropolis munitions plant there's a
story or I am no reporter he is being a
victim of an organized ring yeah yeah
sounds like there might be a story at
the plant Lois Lois
my name is Lois not Lois it was
everybody in Title II to be named wrong
what is happening right now I s
Lois Louise Lucy now I'm so mixed up I
don't know who I am
your perving the creep space and you
belong in a Ralph Bakshi film
[Music]
this is Philadelphia's idea of going
green
hey watchman take your post in the main
shop and be on the alert yes sir thank
you sir
oh pardon me the threatening old guy
standing at door music yeah the BC
factory people are trying to figure out
why Michael fat man is the best Batman
movie in you logically makes no sense
[Music]
Sarah I'm done labeling she Hawks
vibrator now what do I do
[Music]
what upstairs well the plan very
important um who are you what upstairs
twelve o'clock
very important my lips are finally going
to fly off my face I want you to see
this whole Factory is responsible for
building Bill Maher's money ah I wonder
what the big shot was oh they find this
looks like a job for a useless pawn that
was a good job you did on the watchman
last night the Zack Snyder knows how to
destroy a good superhero movie now what
can you do with Superman - the switch on
a plant flow below what then the
watchman here some good snooping there
Lois honey gadget would be proud
[Music]
it's okay on fake news get that good get
that 50 year old midlife crisis having
girl
[Music]
Jesus spider-gwen in heels could move
like that you will join the cult of
fix-it Felix oh yeah took me a while to
see you there
[Music]
okay look I'm an airplane you be to me
don't look up my skirt
[Music]
hey they're putting you in torpedoes 777
that's pretty lucky alright men
now load em a dynamite well that
security guard got huge yeah that's what
happens when you get your guards from
the Sunny Acres retirement all just
another day for the evil blind pellagra
I really need a new day Jones speaking
hello Jones we're ready for the test
send up a torpedo immediately
immediately what's that really warm
thing music the green tractor helping
develop weapons of mass destruction for
80 years
[Music]
here comes torpedo now isn't it's
exciting because naturally for
experimental purposes there is no
explosive in the torpedo there is a
reporter named Lois Lane but I never
liked her columns in a bizarre twist
that pervy guy named Lewis from earlier
saves the day ah did you forget to show
a scene okay standby ready did Superman
say fire I guess he finally fed up with
her
[Music]
well blows me down something's gonna
lose me up I could
[Music]
[Applause]
how did he save her when he came and
opened his eyes
[Music]
Slean miss lane
are you alright super they're about to
blow up the plant and I'm southern now
for some reason most people make a
bubble gum popping sound went punched by
the Man of Steel Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
alright I'll escape and listen nobody
will ever if I was not what I wanted
Superman he looked out on the passenger
side that computers me now watch as he
spells Francis with them
time for me to pick up this truck and
drop it off in a safe way or I could do
this too seems a bit more complicated I
immediately regret this again feel like
we missed the scene somehow well pop
Superman put an end to their little egg
and this wasn't in your flower yeah
you're really good at seeing through
disguises Lois I'm Superman you know
[Music]
you